the first is lean in on service I'm here
to serve I'm here to help I'm trying to
do something of good what's the
intention behind this thing you're about
to do if you're going to go on stage
what's the intention is the intention to
hurt somebody to screw somebody over to
lie to them to cheat no hopefully not
the intention is good the intention is
positive you want to you want to serve
you want to help you want your message
to hopefully impact somebody's life if
you're selling a product or service yes
you want to make money and you're trying
to solve a problem you're trying to help
people so anytime I make it about you
you know the people watching it I make
it personal I focus on service instead
of focusing on me how am I received how
are how are you liking me how is that
guy who passed by what is he thinking
about me anytime I can focus on other
people and the value that they're
hopefully going to get at least with the
intention I wouldn't be maybe so bold or
Brave to say no this is going to be my
best video ever but it's my intention
always it's my intention to try to make
the best video I've ever done and give
as much value as I can and to serve and
hopefully one person is touched by this
video and it means something to them
right so when you're afraid to do
something focus in on service need
motivation what top 10 with believe
Nation hey it's Nina Carmichael and we
made these videos because we know you're
the most ambitious person in your circle
but you know you're capable of more and
you get that Push by surround yourself
with the best so today let's learn from
one of the best my husband Evan
Carmichael and our take on his top 10
rules for Success enjoy
rule number two step in your confidence
reminding yourself every day of how
amazing you are I think it's one of the
greatest gifts you can give yourself and
it's not about ego it's about confidence
confidence comes from a place of
strength ego comes from a place of
weakness and insecurity so it's time to
step into your confidence and remind
yourself of how amazing you really are
this video is gonna help so I used to
have a lot of problems with with ego
versus confidence I used to feel like
who am I why do people need to hear my
story I was profiling all these
different successful entrepreneurs and
people kept asking well where are you
how come we can't see what you're about
where did you come from and I always
felt like my story doesn't matter I'm
profiling Diva Goggins and Steve Jobs
and and all these people why do you care
about I mean sure I sold my first
business had had an exit but it's
nothing compared to what all these other
people have done and I always
shrouded it covered it under ego like
well that's such an egotistical thing to
do
but really I was just playing small I
was cheating people the opportunity to
learn to get better to grow from my
story that my story has value it's the
belief that my story had value that took
some time to really work up even making
videos on my channel the number one most
requested person for top 10 was me and I
resisted for maybe two years of even
making an Evan Carmichael top 10 because
I just felt not good enough I felt like
that's such an ego play and not coming
from a place of confidence and yes my
message has impact has meaning can help
the world and the first Evan Carmichael
top 10 came out from my team so my
birthday birthday I think it was my
birthday birthday or Christmas my team
put together with the with the support
of my hardcore fans my first top ten
you want to watch it
and that's the one that that went live
on the channel and ever since then we've
done a regular series of me being on the
channel but it's it's been a real
progress for me it's been a real
Evolution it's taken me a long time and
hopefully you can get there faster this
has been almost 20 years of me sharing
ideas and content and and slowly
stepping into the light and slowly
building more confidence and more belief
and I hope that
with the content I'm making and the
experiences I'm sharing you can get
there a lot faster rule number three
take the next step the world's biggest
problem is a lack of belief the the
biggest problem for me for you for
Brandon burchard for everybody is a lack
of belief you believe in yourself to the
extent of what you've done that you can
do it again but you don't believe in The
Next Step you don't believe that you can
go from here to here this is why I think
everybody has what I call Michael Jordan
level Talent at something like you're a
genius you are the best in the world at
something and it's not what you what you
went to school for it's not what your
parents taught you it's not what the
people around you are doing it's
probably something very very very
different and unlike your parents or
grandparents it's actually possible now
because of Technology because of the
Internet it's actually possible for you
to go off and be this Michael Jordan
level genius at something you don't need
to have the resources you don't need to
have the education you don't need to
have the connection because it's all the
walls have been broken down and it's
only getting easier
but it's still the lack of belief in the
ability to do the thing
people say well I I think cancer is the
world's biggest problem great I think
cancer should have been solved by now
the woman who would have solved cancer
is a manager at an accounting firm doing
work that she hates because one she
never believes in herself enough to go
down the
route to become a doctor or researcher
and two even if she started she didn't
believe in herself enough that she could
be the genius at it the the Michael
Jordan level genius best in the world or
something and this is this is what
happens we settle we get stuck we get
complacent we we find all these reasons
and excuses why we can't do it we're
really it's just fear and lack of belief
and every time you break through every
every major breakthrough that I've had
in my life has come on the other side of
me believing in myself more that I could
go up and do that thing rule number four
use nose as film use the nose as fuel
and I add this in not because I use it
but because I know it works for a lot of
other people and and I'm channeling Tom
bill you right now this is one of the
things that Tom does that's he credits
to having his success if you know Tom
impact Theory built a billion dollar
business with with Quest and now has
this awesome YouTube channel he has a
list he has a list of all the people who
doubted him who didn't believe in him
and whenever he feels like he really
needs that extra motivation he goes to
that dark place and looks at that list
and say all these people did not believe
in me I'm gonna show them wrong I don't
do that I don't get a lot of power
strength for myself of being in the dark
side of proving somebody wrong but
I think it can be very beneficial for
people and a lot of people do talk about
it so I wanted to at least give that to
you as an option use those no's as fuel
use that your mom telling you that you
suck and you can't make it maybe she
doesn't say that you suck but that you
can't make it using your friends or
haters online saying that you're never
gonna do it using that as fuel to say
I'm gonna show you and prove you wrong I
just think the danger is if you live in
there for too long if you're only fueled
for the dark side it consumes you if
you're only doing something to prove
somebody wrong you're never going to
stay consistent persistent enough
because it's not a good enough reason at
the core of doing the thing has to be
you love doing a thing you want to serve
right you're built to serve you want to
serve you want to help you want to help
right but if you have to channel the
dark side every now and then use those
noses fuel to help you get forward then
go for it and give it a shot also to
make sure you're actually taking action
after watching this video I've designed
a special free worksheet just for this
video the worksheet will highlight all
the lessons learned learned in this
video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet designed specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number five defend your time
your actions have to map to your
Ambitions one of the biggest challenges
people have is figuring out what does
balance look like for you you don't want
to have Jeff bezos's calendar you don't
want to have Evan Carmichael's calendar
either balance looks like something
different to us finding your version of
balance mapping your actions to your
Ambitions and then Having the courage
and the confidence to chase that down
and apply it to your life when the
people around you are saying you're not
you're crazy that's the juice of life
that is where you'll find peace as well
as your success so as an example let me
walk you through a typical week in the
life of Evan Carmichael I like having my
morning routine that I do pretty much
every day of the week I have my evening
routine that I'll do pretty much every
day of the week and then I have
different days for different things I
find that if I have one full day to
focus on just one main task I'm much
more productive so on Mondays is my
mentoring day and I'm spending the whole
day mentoring the people on my team
we're growing we've got over 25 people
on the team and some people I talk to
every week some people every month some
people every quarter but I spend the
whole day just figuring out how can I
make the people on my team better listen
to heard improved training skills all of
it that's my whole day on Monday and all
I'm doing is being in the mentoring Zone
Tuesday is my YouTube day I'm making
videos I'm strategizing I'm planning I'm
creating I'm all in I'm just making
YouTube videos my team doesn't bother me
on Tuesdays unless it's an urgent
emergency they're not connecting with me
on Tuesday because I'm in YouTube mode
Wednesday is my project day I work on
the things that I want to do to grow my
business whatever project is on my mind
right now so right now build to serve
right getting the book out promoting it
uh working on my email campaigns and
sequences and finals and all of that is
most of Wednesdays Thursdays is my
public facing day that's what I'm doing
interviews and hangouts and podcasts and
being on people's Instagram shows and
YouTube shows and radio shows it's all
day it's it's 25 minutes on five minute
break 25 minutes on five minute break my
entire Thursday Fridays is my CEO day
and so I'm doing bigger picture projects
to help build my business and Grow It
Forward Saturday becomes fun day
Saturday is when I spend the day with my
wife normally
I'm planning a new food place for us to
go eat and looking at festivals for us
to go to and enjoy uh we're in
coronavirus time right now so we're in
lockdown but it's basically non-work day
and I'm in charge of planning a day for
myself my wife to have a fun day that I
know she's going to enjoy Sunday is
family at midday and that's when we're
doing Costco and dishes and laundry and
we'll do the dishes more than just
Sunday put laundry and clean up the
condo and going to Home Depot or
whatever has to get done that's more
kind of on the admin side and when you
have clearly defined days for for your
life at least for my life it prevents
bleed so for example if you know we
really have to go to Costco to get
something not on a Saturday nope you
have to defend your time you got to
defend your time because other things
will constantly attack in your time if
you're ever at the point where you feel
like everybody has something for you to
do and you have no time for yourself
it's it's your fault you haven't put the
boundaries up you haven't put the gates
up you haven't protected your time
enough with the shield that you have
that's what you need to do on a
consistent basis and say I love you I
respect you I want to help you I want to
work with you this is my time
I can help you over here
and and the caveat is when you show up
for them you're with them rule number
six follow through act on your
uncomfortable ideas we get great ideas
as entrepreneurs we get great ideas and
especially moments of boldness and
confidence and courage you get great
ideas it could be when you're in the
shower on an airplane or traveling you
get great ideas for what you want to do
and then tomorrow you tell yourself I
can't do that that's crazy that that's
too hard that's that's scary that's
uncomfortable
teach yourself to act on your crazy
ideas is how you start to build
confidence because if you come up
against a crazy idea and then you allow
yourself to say well that's too scary
that's too hard that's too difficult I
can't do that what you've taught
yourself is you don't have courage
you've taught yourself to come up with
ideas but then not trust in yourself and
so when you come up with the next idea
you tell yourself I don't trust myself
when you set a goal for yourself to hit
hit some Big Goal you don't believe
yourself anymore because all you've done
is taught yourself that you set goals
you have ideas and you never follow
through you've built this identity of
I'm somebody who doesn't follow through
that's what you need to start to destroy
that's where you need to destroy and
squash out of your life that identity of
I don't follow through your ideas are
genius your ideas are amazing this is
why play bigger tourism help you get an
idea and you're in your awesome
environment act on it do something lean
into the uncomfortable lean into the
things that cause a little bit of your
heart to beat and cause some anxiety
that's how you start to make the shift
rule number seven get specific deciding
your top three goals right now what are
your top three goals most important
things to you right now what are your
priorities the three big things that
have to happen for you what are they get
clear get specific if you don't know
what they are that's why you're not
chasing anything big down
if you even thought about it then then
that's the problem you're stuck in these
small projects for Life what are your
three big goals for your business and
your life right now rule number eight be
around ambitious people
staying in your cocoon and only hanging
around the same five to ten people if
those people are not more ambitious than
you then you're gonna stay stuck you're
gonna feel good about yourself because
you're pushing everybody and you're
optimistic and and you feel good
relative to where they're at but you
won't be growing you you are probably
the most ambitious person that you know
you're the you're the most positive most
uplifting most energetic most ambitious
person of any of the people that you
hang out with and that's great and
fulfilling and you can serve them and
help them but it limits your own growth
you stay stuck and you stay super slow
growing and so you need to inject people
who have a greater belief system than
you into your life to make you feel like
you can grow and continue to get better
and that could be somebody who's
actually in your life quick like side
note if there's anybody in your life
at all who you've met once twice four
times right it doesn't have to be your
family somebody that you've hung out
with and met that made you feel better
about yourself when you left them holy
cow hang on to that person I love the
what I say collect good people hang on
to those people find a way to to do a
business with them find a way to spend
time with them find a way to to hang out
with them but Brandon burchard reaching
out to me to do this business together
right like he's finding ways to hang out
with what he thinks is good people so
you know that's that's a tremendous
Honor on my part
so if you have anybody like that and
again it's probably not the closest
people to you you have to go on The
Fringe the people you have spent some
time with try to spend more time with
them find the reason to do it whether
it's starting the business together
whether it's just having a monthly
coffee together just to connect again do
it
if you don't have anybody like that in
your life don't stress that's why
there's videos that's why there's books
that's why there's podcasts if you
watched if you actually started your day
with an espresso video every day your
life will start to shift you won't
notice it tomorrow or the next day or
the next day but a month later three
months later six months later you start
to see I'm I'm thinking bigger now I'm
I'm more bold I'm more confident I I
want to do bigger things with my life
well why is that it's because you're
hanging around people who are doing
bigger things with their life even
virtually so I can learn a lot from
Brendan who I've met and now doing a
partnership with but also from Oprah
Winfrey and Elon Musk and all these
people the more I'm around them the more
they pull me to want to think bigger
rule number nine focus on progress focus
on progress when you focus on progress
instead of the end result that's where I
think you can keep your motivation and
keep your belief when I first started
making my videos I wasn't getting any
results right nobody was watching nobody
was commenting I felt like a loser right
nobody cares it's not happening I'm not
getting the results understand that you
very rarely ever get results at the
beginning if you focus on just getting
the results at the beginning you're
likely going to get too discouraged and
quit it's not that the results aren't
important it's just people have a Too
Short an attention span and when you
focused on the result at the beginning
it is too discouraging and you do give
up instead you focus on the progress are
you getting better are you learning was
your video better than last time did you
show up with more energy than last time
did you have better points than you did
last time was that sales call you did
better than the one last time was your
next test better than it was yesterday
right are you getting better because if
you can say I'm getting better if you if
you're making videos and you look back a
week later a month later and said man I
still suck but I'm better than I was
a week ago a month ago and you can focus
on the progress at least for me it
really helps fuel my motivation my
belief in myself that hey if I made that
growth from here to here then I can make
more growth from here to here and at the
beginning here's the thing at the
beginning the growth is pretty fast when
you're learning something from from
scratch at the beginning you actually
learn very quickly
it's at the end that it gets harder
for me right now to keep getting better
is harder I don't see as big a return on
my on my progress as Evan Chronicle
growth from last week to this week from
last month to this month how much better
am I on camera from last month to this
month not that much
it requires even more effort and even
more mentorship and even more practice
and training to get better as when
you're close to the top
at the beginning you can learn really
quickly and there's a lot of progress
the flip side for me now is lots of
results right when you start actually
getting good that's when the results
kick in
so then you can start focusing on the
results like hey is this working or not
is this video doing better than the last
one or not because you start getting
some data and results to work with
so at the beginning you're focusing on
the progress am I getting better am I
improving and am I learning is it better
than I was last week and then as that
starts to taper off you might get
frustrated with your progress but good
news
you're going to start seeing results
come in and that'll keep you motivated
to keep going as well rule number 10 the
last one before our very special bonus
clip be
Doer
amazing message but too many of you who
are perfectionists will hear that
message and use it as an excuse for not
taking action I'm a firm believer that
planners need to do more and doers need
to plan more and here's the problem
planners do not need to plan more you're
already great at planning you will plan
plan plan plan your life away and never
actually take any kind of action and so
for the perfectionists out there for the
planners who want to have the perfect
Plan before you do anything this is an
amazing message but you're not hearing
it correctly it's not don't compromise
and having the perfect plan and just sit
in your room all day and don't pick any
action because Steve Jobs was a doer
this is a hard lesson that I had to
learn myself because I lost a 40 million
dollar deal in my first business when I
was 21 22.
because I was a perfectionist because
everything had to be perfect because I
didn't want to compromise that's how I
interpreted the message but as a result
I didn't do anything and just kept
planning and I lost the deal became
between us and our biggest competitor
and we were really late to the party
because we didn't do the right thing and
we ended up losing a deal
now would we have won it if I had done
more maybe not 100 but I would have had
a better shot at it and so ever since
then I've been trying to release that
perfectionist habit it's still in there
I still love the plane but the people
have the most success have that
combination of planning but then
actually doing
hard work is your ticket in
hard work doesn't guarantee your success
but it's your ticket in there's nobody
who you look up to who you respect who
you want to be like who did not work
incredibly hard to get to where they're
at now people say work smart work smart
work yes there's lots of people who work
hard and never get anywhere close to
their goals there's lots of people who
work incredibly hard who who stay
earning minimum wage their entire life
because they didn't work smart they were
only working hard but there's nobody who
just works smart and doesn't work hard
even if they're fooling you with their
pictures on Instagram it's that
combination of working hard plus working
smart I've covered
most of these people I've hung out with
a lot of these people I see the
incredible smarts that they have and the
activities that they choose but also
just the work ethic they have the show
up every day and stay consistent on
their goals
so in this video I'm going to try to
give you some tips and steps on how to
actually do it like how do you stay
consistent how do you figure out how to
work hard but also work smart on
accomplishing your mission so
let's get it started first off you have
to actually love the thing right I mean
how many times have you started a
business because you thought it was
going to make you a lot of money
be honest I've done it too you started
business because you think it's going to
make you money and then you quickly get
bored of it you quickly realize it's not
making you money and you don't want to
do it anymore
and you close it down and move on to the
next thing and so many people are just
opportunity hopping
jump to the next thing and the next
thing and the next thing the next thing
the next thing without ever actually
loving any of the things and so you
never you never actually win you might
make a little bit of money here and
there you know you might be able to pay
some of your bills off it's great but
you're not living the life that you want
because you're just opportunity happened
instead of actually finding the thing
that you love doing where the number one
rule for Success if you watch any of my
videos we've covered so many people take
my word for it or go do your own
research the number one number one guys
number one rule for success is that you
have to love what you're doing you have
to love the process the actual work that
you're doing
it doesn't feel like work because you
like it so much making videos doesn't
feel like work because I like it because
I like the process I like making it I I
like making this video more than
getting something like this right it's
great hey a million subscribers awesome
or the other channel is great
but I like I like the feeling of making
this video and knowing that you right
now are watching it
that means something to me I like it
that's why I keep going otherwise it's
crazy you know
10 000 videos plus later why like how do
you keep going because I like it doesn't
feel like work to me I talk about it
when I do interviews like how people ask
me how have you not burnt out already
like so many people are burning out on
YouTube but well it's not just YouTube
It's entrepreneurship people burn out of
Entrepreneurship not just having a
YouTube channel why do you burn out of
Entrepreneurship because you stop
actually liking it's too much of the
work that you're doing that you don't
like anymore
right there's too much of the work that
you're doing you might still love the
vision for where you're going if you
don't know the vision you got to get out
ASAP
but you might still love the vision but
you're just taking on too much activity
that you don't like doing anymore
so when I'm talking to somebody on their
podcast I like I like doing interviews
it makes me happy it brings me joy to
try to
hit somebody else's audience right they
try to spread believe to an even wider
net
and so if I'm talking to somebody say
well what does this work for you because
in talking to you this doesn't work for
me
this is fine
I'm Gonna Leave This interview with more
energy than I came in that's a sign that
you're doing the right thing so I like
this thank you you're you're giving me
you know I'm giving you content and
exposure for your channel but you're
giving me a gift because
this is fun you're giving me more energy
it doesn't feel like work
the second it starts to feel like work
you have to adjust and it might be it
might be a big adjustment maybe you
shouldn't be doing your business anymore
period because you just opportunity
hopping you don't actually love the
thing
or maybe you just need to make a minor
adjustment and realize okay this makes
sense as a strategy but it's just not
the right strategy for me I need to move
on and do something else even though it
works for some other people it's not me
I don't want to do it
so that's how we start transitioning to
working smart right so working hard is
you showing up every day working towards
your goals but that your purpose means
something to you and that the work you
do you actually enjoy and having fun in
the working smart is then figuring out
there's so many different ways to win
inside your industry there's so many
different ways to win there's so many
people who have won
and there's not just one path this is
where we get locked up is feeling like I
have to do it this way but you don't
actually love doing it that way
and the second you start taking things
on because you think it's the smart
thing to do but you have no interest in
doing it you will never win you will
never win doing work that you hate it's
not gonna happen you will never win
doing work that you hate you'll say that
you'll do whatever it takes you won't
you'll quit you'll give up on it because
you don't like it
chasing the goal alone is not enough you
have to actually enjoy the process of
getting to the goal that the process
becomes more important than the goal
gives you more satisfaction and
happiness and pleasure than hitting the
goal how many times have you hit a goal
and then been disappointed after right
he's like oh what's next sometimes
borderline depression right
Ted Turner's dad had a goal to hit a
million dollars he did it and then he
killed himself because he thought things
were going to change but he realized his
life was still the same
so having goals are really good and
important but more important than the
goal is the process of accomplishing the
goal you have to actually like the work
so how do you be smart well you have to
you have to do things that bring value
to people that you also enjoy
so in the course of my career on YouTube
at least said
got a bunch of great compliments the two
that stand out in this context are
garyvee and Ed mylett where garyvee said
I'm the content DJ that inspires people
and said hey you watch so many videos
and then DJ it to inspire people and Ed
mylett said
that I'm the modern day Napoleon Hill
that Napoleon Hills the the greatest
person in person development history and
that I'm the modern day Napoleon Hill
now when they both sat down like
I'm still working on receiving
compliments so I was kind of Blown Away
by both of them and then I asked hey
well can I use that in my in my bio or
my profiles but what what I do is
I love I love modeling success you know
it's why I make all this content it's
why it's why I have all these people you
know behind me on the wall you know we
got we got Steve Jobs and epiganini and
my parents and Howard Schultz and Kanye
West like I love modeling success
and and I want to share my own voice my
own thoughts my own opinions my own
learnings my own stories my own lessons
and somewhere in that mix is now Evan
Carmichael
where some people are if you look at
Gary or Ed or whoever else they're
they're just sharing their own thoughts
for the most part they might have guests
on the interviews uh they might
occasionally have a quote from somebody
else but it's it's their own views and
opinions
I never needed to be the guy you know I
like sharing other people's stuff I like
sharing what I learned from their story
and and I've reluctantly kind of stepped
forward to share my own I used to think
nobody would care about my story or
what I had to say or why would you care
about me when I'm showcasing Elon Musk
like who am I but people kept asking for
my story where I came from so I started
sharing it more and so in that mix
became Evan Carmichael that's how I'm
different than everybody else same thing
for you
know what do you love doing that then
can also bring value to other people and
what combinations of things can you
bring together instead of thinking I can
do this or I can do this in the mix is
your next great opportunity
when you can take two or three of your
interests and not do them as the or
right instead of thinking or you think
and
instead of or or you think and and but
not three different businesses this is
where people get tripped up it's not
three different businesses it's one
business that does all three of those
things combined in a way that nobody
else has done it before
because nobody can replicate that
the thing that you love doing or the
things that you love doing smush
together that don't make sense for
anybody else is and that is how you're
gonna end up winning that's how you're
gonna win
[Music]
James alticher calls it idea sex so you
have one idea and another idea and they
have sex and it out comes your your
great idea
I like it
that's how you start working smart
so working hard as you take it in
working hard if you're not willing to
work hard you're just not ever going to
win period how do you work hard well you
actually have to like the work so it
doesn't feel like work that Jerry
Seinfeld calls it the torture you can
endure that is torture for other people
but for you he's like this is I like
this this is fun this doesn't feel like
torture yeah if making the idea of
making 10 000 videos 12 000 videos
whatever
that would be torture for a lot of
people it's like okay that's cool I like
it let's go let's make another ten
thousand let's get going and then inside
of that is what do you love doing that
can bring value to other people in a way
that only you can do it by mixing some
of the things your passions your
interests together that have never been
mixed before together in that unique way
that's how you're going to win instead
of saying that that's not practical
instead of saying that
um they're two different businesses
instead of saying nobody's gonna care no
no no that's how you're gonna win
you mix those things together
focus on how you can use that mix to
bring value to your customers
and now nobody can touch you for people
who say people message me and say hey
Evan this person is copying you this
person is also doing top 10 rules of
success this person is like I don't care
like I spend zero time thinking about
that because if you
are just trying to be Evan Carmichael
you're never going to be here from
Carmichael right the most you're going
to be is an Evan Carmichael Jr
instead of trying to be an Elvis
impersonator go make your own music
right so anybody who's just trying to
copy me I don't I don't care about it
it's the people who are creating new
Innovative things that I consider to be
the real competition
hard work is your ticket in
you have to love what you're doing that
allows you to keep going
then you have to figure out inside of
what you love how can you combine your
interests your passions your special
things that make you a special unique
Snowflake and bring value to people
and when you figure that out that's the
unique angle of working hard plus
working smart that won't even feel like
you're
working hard or even working that smart
you're just doing you
and helping people
and that's how you win figuring out your
core values I think is one of the most
important exercises that you can do as a
human being
like how do you know how to live your
life how do you wake up every day and do
what you want to do how do you have any
Clarity on what to do next when you
don't know what you stand for you don't
know your most important core value it's
the reason why I wrote your one word
I don't know how many years ago the
concept is you have one most important
core value what is it figure it out when
you understand what it is it'll shine a
giant Spotlight on your life to realize
oh this is why I'm not happy like if you
are ever not happy
frustrated stressed out
it's because there's too many things
that are going on in your life that are
out of
congruence with your single most
important core value
so if you look at mine it's belief right
I believe is my single most important
provide Okay cool so I'm happy when I'm
doing things that make me feel believe
and it's something that you you have for
yourself but it's also something that
then you give to other people so you're
on a mission the idea becomes I want to
spread belief for myself and I also want
to help other people believe in
themselves more whatever you come up
with is a core value is for you is what
you still need the most right now I
still need belief right now
but it's also something that we want to
give to other people whether it's the
world if you're watching this video is
probably world big mission but uh it
could just be the closest people to you
you know if you're saying the most
important core value is family then you
want to bring more family to your family
every single most important core value
is belonging then you want to give
belonging to everybody to yourself you
still need to feel more belonging
yourself and you want to give that to
the world or your closest friends and
family
but that's that's the game you have to
figure out your single most important
core value
if you feel like you're being pulled in
a thousand directions that's why you
don't know what you stand for if you
feel uneasy about something or unsure
about a decision that's also why you
don't know what you're saying for and
when you figure that out it gives you
the courage to take the action required
when you understand what your single
most important core value is it allows
you
to step into your career yourself to
step into your bold self it gives you
the permission to move forward where old
you wouldn't have done it you know if
you had those moments where you really
want to do something
you're inspired you got a great idea as
if you want to serve you want to help
you think this could be amazing and then
you stop yourself you know you stop
yourself oh I who am I I can't do that
I'm not I'm not well known enough I
don't have the money I didn't go to
school for this I don't have the
connections with the parents right we
stop ourselves
we we we're planning to plan and getting
ready to get ready but we never actually
do the thing well figuring out your core
value
allows you to have the courage and
strength to step into who you want to be
how can my one word be believe if I'm
not willing to do the things to believe
in myself even something like this
feeling on the street this used to
terrify me I remember the first video
that I made when I was walking down the
street
uh it's probably about a decade ago my
agent challenged me to do it and I was
terrified I was terrified the people
might judge me I was terrified that uh
just looking foolish and looking bad I
don't know I was just terrified filming
in public and I remember I was filming
and I made sure I walked down just this
really quiet street where nobody would
see me and made sure I looked around and
nobody was there and I started filming
and then there was a male woman who came
by she was delivering mail I didn't see
her before I started filming and so
as she walked by I I thought I was like
this
put the camera down you know it's like
I'm not doing anything nope and then
when she left she's like okay back to
filming and uh
you know now now I mean how many
thousands of videos later I'm much more
able to get out in front of the camera
and create but what's the thing that
helps me push what's the help what's the
thing that gives me the confidence or
courage to do that thing that was
incredibly scary at the time well
believe hey my one word is belief my
most important core value is believe so
I need to I need to step into it it's a
it's a constant reminder
it always forces you to be not the
version that somebody else wants for you
but the version that you want for you
believe was was is inside me it's not
that it was just given to me by somebody
you don't have to have Believers your
core value either you can figure what
yours is
but if ever you're stuck with a big
decision
and you're not sure what to do and you
actually know what your most important
core value is then guess what happens it
forces you to go and take some action
because otherwise you're operating
against yourself and you don't need
somebody yelling at you or telling you
what you should do you know what you
should do because they have the
awareness around your core value when I
wrote your one word it was it was
designed for entrepreneurs
because it's about how to find your core
value but then how to build into a
business and
I was surprised that a lot of the people
who liked the book were not just the
entrepreneurs but the the spouses and
the family members of the entrepreneurs
who read the book to say okay they don't
want to start a business but they need
this first part kids in school are
reading the book and send me pictures
and tweets as they go through the
curriculum to figure out what their most
important core value is like can you
imagine being in grade six
seven eight ten
and knowing what your most important
core value is and using that as a lens
for which you can make decisions for the
rest of your life
how beautiful is that
I wish I had that I mean that's why
that's why we do what we do right that's
why that's why authors write books
that's why entrepreneurs start
businesses is we want to solve the
problems that we had for ourselves when
we want to make the path a little bit
easier for other people right that's why
we do what we do
so how do you find your core value well
you can you can pick up your one word
you can pick up built to serve but as a
starting point
think about who your favorite teacher
was growing up and why
think about your favorite teacher of all
time mine was mine was Madame Farr who
was my teacher Mentor in my last year of
high school but who was yours who's your
favorite teacher growing up and why and
specifically on the why wasn't because
they taught you a certain subject I
didn't like my damn far because she
taught me French right I don't even use
French day to day at all even living in
Canada we don't use French
but uh but shocked me to believe in
myself
so there's one what's your favorite
movie of all time and why mine is
Seabiscuit I love sea biscuits about
this horse it's way too small to win not
supposed to win a jockey that's way too
big to win and not supposed to win an
owner that has no money and is not
supposed to win it's like all the stuff
that's not supposed to happen and yet
they all find each other and somehow A
Miracle of Miracles they figured out and
they win a whole bunch of races it's
based off a true story it's it's a
belief story at least for me when I
think about that movie why do I love it
well it's about belief
think about your parents
you know maybe you love your parents
maybe you hate your parents uh what do
you what was the biggest lesson you
learned from them like what did you love
the most even if you didn't like your
parents or didn't think they were there
for you or you know whatever what what
did you love about them or if there's
nothing redeemable that you can find
then what did you wish that they gave
you what do you want to give to your
kids right current kids or future kids
if you had to give them one lesson what
would that be again mine is believed my
parents always taught me hey you're
having Australia Carmichael you can do
anything you believe that you can so
believe is a Common Thread through all
these things if you think about this why
is this why does this matter if you
think about all the things that made you
come alive all the things all the best
moments in your life all the positivity
all the happiness all the the best
moments in your life
there's a Common Thread between them you
know so for me it's bully Matt I'm far
Seabiscuit my parents the Common Thread
is believe
when you figure what that threat is for
you what it allows you to do is now
design a life going forward with more
intention
so now instead of it happening by
accident you know I just happened if I'm
at Empire I just happened to find Sea
Biscuit it wasn't intentional most of us
are not doing that with any level of
intentionality it's just that
random things happen and every now and
then one of those random things are good
right but now it allows you to design a
life with more intentionality to say
this is what I stand for
this is who I am at the core
these are the things that make me happy
I want to chase down the feeling of X
believe for me right I want to chase
down that feeling I believe more I want
to be around the people who help make me
believe I want to create content in the
business that inspires people to believe
I want to hire teammates
people on my in my business we got 40
people now I want to I want to bring on
people who believe in the mission
believe in spreading believe believe in
each other right it's like it just gives
so much more clarity
and intentionality for the rest of your
life
and so I think it's one of the most
important exercises that you can ever do
just as a human I don't know why we
don't teach this stuff in school you
should
because how do you operate your life
without knowing what you're saying for
how do you operate without knowing who
you are
that seems crazy
and it's not that difficult and you
don't have to go meditate on the
mountain for five years to figure it out
you don't have to hire a ten thousand
dollar coach to figure it out just ask
yourself those questions
who's your favorite teacher growing up
and why
what's your favorite movie of all time
and why what did you love about your
parents or what's the gift that you want
to give your kids
the most important core value coming
through those things
that'll give you a much better path and
direction
and Clarity and strength and courage
for the rest of your life your
environment creates your energy
when you are at home and you are down
and you're out and you just stay home
and you never get any fresh air and you
never get people around you to push you
and make you feel like things are
possible then you stay stuck
and when you get outside or when you go
to an event and when you meet people
even if you're not there to learn even
if you haven't picked up anything at
that event just the fact that you got
out and you met people and you change
your environment and you got some
sunshine can make a world of difference
it is
incredibly difficult to be an
entrepreneur
it's hard
it's hard not just in that you're you
know not seeing results at the beginning
and you're trying to figure out how to
make money but it's also hard that
you're by yourself
you know and you doubt yourself and you
have insecurities and fears and you
don't know if it's going to work out or
not
it's really hard and so when you're
stuck doing everything on your own and
then the fears and the doubts and skirt
is creep in when you're by yourself at
home
that's the path down to the scary Lane
you know that's the path down to anxiety
and stress and depression and it's why a
big reason why we stay stuck and while
we start and stop and start and stop and
start and stop
and and can't stay consistent have you
ever been on that entrepreneur roller
coaster where you're motivated and
excited and things are great one day and
the next day you wake up and it's kind
of not so great anymore has that
happened to you that happened to me a
lot that's for sure in the early days I
mean I quit on my business partner
because I wasn't getting results and I
just felt like a loser felt like a total
idiot because nothing was working out
um
worst day of my life it wasn't that I
didn't have the heart or the ambition to
do great things or didn't believe in the
company it's just it wasn't working out
nothing was working out and and I felt
terrible about it
and the big reason why is because I was
alone I was by myself I was alone
I didn't tell my friends I mean I guess
I had a business partner but I felt bad
talking about it with with him and
I stay stuck
and so
it took me a bunch of years to figure
out
these things that I'm about to share
with you today about some hacks that
I've used to help me maintain the
momentum
so let's dive in the first is every
morning I go for a believe walk
and the belief walk is just me going
outside and selling our rain or snow
here in Canada I go for a belief walk
and on that walk
it's just a way to start my day because
no matter how great a day I might have
today tomorrow I wake up and it's
another day even today was rough day I
only slept two and a half hours or
something last night so it's a very
non-typical day energy not where it
needs to be or usually is in the morning
and so first thing let's get up
and you know give us our a little bit of
Grace it may not be as great a day as as
we usually do but I'm gonna go for my
believe walk and just getting outside
just getting some fresh air on my face
just
you know having some sun with me just
not being in my my home
already starts to lighten the mood
already starts to give me more energy
and so every day I go for a believe walk
you know unless I am just completely
incapacitated and wake up get some sun
on my face wherever I am and get my
belief walking just think about what's
the kind of day I want to have you know
what's my intention for the day and try
to set that up two try to go to events
and to the idea of you know buy tickets
to things
it could be things that you don't care
about but it could also be things that
you actually you know you're going to be
around some people and every time I go
away to an event this is why you know a
pandemic has been hard because he's just
been sitting inside but every time that
I get to go away to some kind of event
whether I learn something there or not
from the speakers or the people there I
always come back with Renewed Energy
with renewed excitement with renewed
ideas even if you just go on remember
going on vacations you know you go on a
vacation and you sit on the beach and I
hate the beach you know I hate sitting
there on the beach
I'll go and and sit on the beach here
one day and then all of a sudden get
bored of sitting on the beach I want to
do something and so I'm then instantly
pulling out my notebook and coming up
with ideas or reading books and you come
away refreshed even though the goal
wasn't necessarily business but you get
new ideas for your business when you get
out of your routine your your
you know the routine is great but when
you feel like you're stuck
then adding a little bit of variety to
it can really help this is the balance
that we have to do as entrepreneurs we
love variety we love new we love we love
trying all sorts of new things but if we
don't stay consistent on something we'll
never accomplish our goals but if all we
do is do the same thing constantly and
we stay consistent on doing the same
thing we end up getting bored and hating
our business and now we just bought
ourselves a job so it's that constant
balance where if you haven't had any
variety for a while you need to add more
variety in and if you haven't had
consistency for a while you need to add
more consistency with this ebb and flow
that's part of being an entrepreneur
that I think you need to build in so
just scheduling time so you have your
believed watches I do every every
morning to set me up for the day and
then schedule in time to be able to go
off and uh just just not be at home you
know whether it's a conference or an
event a vacation just something to
refresh my mind
and then the third thing is just join a
community
it was one of the biggest things that I
missed was I had no Community I was
doing it all by myself and I'm being
introverted and being shy I don't
naturally seek out community community
and talking to people it's not something
that that is normally in my mind and I'm
nervous you know going up and talking to
people so it's harder for someone like
me and maybe someone like you to join a
community but man what a difference it
makes
I think of movement makers and this is
really the program I wish I had when I
was getting started you know movement
makers is yes advice for me and we meet
every two weeks and talk about your the
movement you're trying to build and
everything you're trying to create but
more than that is a connection Community
to each other that
if you want to be a thought leader you
are not by yourself think about what
you're trying to do if you think of what
I was trying to do like I'm the only one
who I know who's trying to do this you
know who are your friends who are trying
to make YouTube videos who else is
walking through this mall making content
right nobody so who do you know who's
doing what you want to do probably
nobody and who who do you know who's
doing what you want to do at a high
level and who's ambitious and hungry
probably nobody right like you are
probably the one who is the most kind
optimistic ambitious person around you
and so when you start to get around
other people who are like that as well I
mean what a huge difference it makes and
so you can look at mover makers if you
want to be a thought leader but just in
general to find a community find a
community of people who are doing the
thing that you are trying to do even if
they haven't done it yet but they're
ambitious and they're hungry and they're
trying to do it
it changed your life
certainly business is really hard and
you know this if you're watching this
video you made it this far you know what
you know it's hard
the environment that you're around
is only partially supporting you
and when you can shake it up when you
can get outside and go for walks get
some sun on your face when you can get
out of your home and go to events and
just be around other people who are
doing things and when you can join a
community of people who are trying to do
something similar to what you're doing
it can make all the difference in the
world you've got a great idea
you're doing it for the right reason
you've got a noble cause and if you feel
like you have those energy dips where
one day you're on top of the world and
it's all exciting and the next day you
kind of wake up and you're you're in a
rut
if that right continues on you know for
for days or weeks it's a sign not that
you're on the that this isn't right for
you it's just a sign that you need to
add a little more variety and remind
yourself of who you are focus on one
idea and make it work focus on one
business model focus on one Revenue
stream focus on one social media Network
and make it work so many times we're
focused on too many things we're
distracted and our entrepreneur ADHD
kicks in and as a result nothing happens
for all the people who are telling you
to have 13 different passive income
streams because if one goes away you
still have all these other 12. most of
people who start off doing that make
zero money from all of the passive
income streams you're making ten dollars
a month four dollars a month seven
dollars a month where instead if you
could focus on one thing
and maximize it and make it amazing and
put your energy into it you will see
exponential results I look at social
media as an example and I just finished
this training where we did the seven day
build to Surf challenge it was amazing
had so many awesome new thought leaders
coming to the program people have got a
big message want to serve and one of the
questions I kept getting asking is
how do I be on every social media
platform how do I be everywhere how do I
get started and just blow up everywhere
and it's like you don't right the answer
is don't don't don't try to do that
if you are the person right now who is
trying to be everywhere look at your
social media accounts
chances are you're sucking everywhere
chances are not not you suck as a human
just the results aren't there the
effort's not there the energy is not
there because you're so forcing yourself
to just get out there and create content
and be in all the platforms
that you also have a million other
things that you have to do and so as a
result you're you're creating
really mediocre content
content that people aren't interacting
with and if people don't like what
you're putting up it's not going to lead
to results for your business and so much
much much much much better it doesn't
mean that you can't be there you know
it doesn't mean that at some point you
can't be there that as you build your
brand and you get bigger and you hire a
team and you have more money that you
can start to do this but much better at
the beginning is to figure out
what is the one platform what is the one
Revenue stream what is the one business
model the one thing that if I focus on
that thing
it's going to lead to results so then I
can scale
entrepreneurs have a hard time with this
because we want to do so many things we
have our add brain going on and
we don't want to just do one thing we
also feel like it
is limiting for what we want to do right
if you have a big Vision a big mission a
giant goal for what you want to
accomplish
doing just this one little piece of it
feels too small
the way that I would structure it and
think about it is this is just a
sequence
you still get to do everything
you still get to do it all
you just have to go in order you have to
create a sequence that the thing that
you need to focus on at the beginning of
your business whether it's your Revenue
stream whether it's social media success
whatever it is what you have to figure
out is how do I start to as soon as
possible get a sustainable business for
myself
so that I can quit my job if you have
one so that I can bring income in for
myself my family so I can start to
afford to hire a team even if it's
part-time or one person so you can scale
up your company so that I can then go
off and do all the other things because
some of your ideas are are amazing and
huge and require more people and time
and effort and energy and some of the
ideas can get started a lot faster
and so if you want to go and accomplish
your big goal your big dream your big
mission then it's important to think
about the sequence of things that
instead of doing everything all at once
and as a result all of the results being
mediocre focus on the one thing that if
you push that lever you really maximize
that thing
you could start to make more money you
could start to have more impact you can
start to have more reach you can start
to see more success that then allows you
to bring on more people to help you
build and scale
for me we've got 37 people on the team
now
and
I can do so much more you know because
we got team then if it was just me by
myself doing everything and so in
building my mission I want to solve the
world's biggest problem right people
don't believe in themselves enough and
so in building that up I need people I
need help I need support I need team I
need I need a lot more than what I've
got right now
but and be able to build a business that
can bring in money then I can afford the
higher team that helps me accomplish a
lot more things and take on a lot more
projects but if I was at the very
beginning of what I was doing right now
I would not be doing most of the things
that I'm doing right now
I'd still be accomplishing and going
after the same mission
but I'd have to pick one thing to focus
on
I think the one thing at the beginning
that I think I could make some money
doing this so that I can live I can I
can pay you know rent mortgage
I can pay my internet bills I could pay
for some food not not living you know
fancy life but just being able to live
and survive so I don't have to have a
job and then I would start thinking okay
how do I then scale this one thing that
I'm working on
to build up to the point where I can
remove myself or at least take some of
the pieces off so that I can hire a team
to help build and scale and grow if I
look back at my YouTube Journey here I
did everything at the beginning you know
I I uh I filmed it I researched it I
edited it I did all of it and it took a
crazy amount of time and I made a lot of
mistakes and I did a lot of stuff that I
probably shouldn't have done and
just by focusing on that thing and
making content and creating videos it
then allowed me to make a little bit of
money but then I could hire my first
part-time editor that then turned into a
full-time editor that turned into a
second editor and a research person that
turned into someone helping with the
thumbnails and the graphics and it
continues to build up and scale but
everything I was doing myself in a
mediocre way but getting it done
to then be able to scale out a team and
so most people are just stuck doing too
many things you're stuck like look at
what you're doing on a day-to-day basis
look at your calendar you have a limited
amount of time right you have a limited
amount of time there's only so much you
can do in in a day in a week you have
other responsibilities maybe you have a
job maybe you have family kids health
that you have to look after you know
there's a certain amount of time that
you have that you can dedicate to this
thing that time needs to go into the
right efforts
and again it's great to have that big
mission and big gold and big dream but
if you have a limited amount of time
every day or every week
and you are
trying to create 13 passive income
streams with that limited amount of time
no one of the streams ever gets enough
energy enough effort Enough of Your Mind
space enough of your creativity Enough
of Your Love to ever become anything
and so you're diversifying way too
quickly you're diversifying way too soon
and apply that for anything that you're
working on apply that to your your
business and the and the opportunities
that you're chasing the Partnerships
that you're looking at the things that
you're saying yes to the social media
networks that you're trying to be on
do yourself a favor
don't try to be everywhere not yet
right just understand there's a sequence
to things and you can make it so much
easier for yourself to have more impact
to make more money to have a bigger
influence to be more proud of yourself
to start getting more success and more
results and more momentum so much easier
if you just sequence it out
so that you don't have to do everything
all at once you don't have to feel the
the handcuffs and the Restriction of
saying well I don't want to do this one
thing for the rest of my life this is
where it gets
you know entrepreneur Ade kicks in right
and we don't want to be locked in I
don't want to do the same thing forever
well you don't you won't do it forever
that's not the point the point is not to
do this one thing forever that if you
took these 10 opportunities in front of
you
you could do all 10. you could do all
10.
just not all 10 at the same time because
if you do all 10 at the same time none
of them are going to work out
and often it's a small opportunity that
can pay you more quickly
that can start to build the momentum for
you so if you have your list of your 10
opportunities in front of you 10 things
that you could do great look at what
order should I go in
so I can start making money and start
building momentum one last quick example
I look at a lot of thought leaders a lot
of people have a message a lot of people
want to be speakers and authors and
coaches and influencers and
they've got big goals and big Ambitions
for what they want to create
when I'm helping someone like that
usually the first option is coaching
the best thing to do at the beginning is
coaching so we're going to dive into one
specific business model right if you can
look at let's say be a speaker
getting brand deals as an influencer
writing a book and coaching if we had
those are four opportunities in front of
you right let's say so what did I say
being a speaker getting paid to speak
getting paid to do brand deals getting
paid to be an author and selling books
um even selling courses your own
materials and training and Etc and
coaching
those are those are you know four or
five different business models that you
can go through perfect
at the beginning which one is the best
what should you focus on
be coaching
why
people don't like the idea of coaching
because you're trading your time for
money right I don't want to trade my
time for money okay
well what are you doing right now you
know you're at a job because if you're
at a job you're trading your time for
money
if you have unlimited time to figure
stuff out and you have you have a giant
bank account then you could do something
different but if you need to start to
make money to build this thing up then
yes you're trading your time for money
but it's a faster path to get you out of
your job and into your business
full-time
where everything else takes a lot more
time
speaking takes an incredible amount of
time if you want to if you want to be a
paid speaker and and get paid enough
that it's actually meaningful
it takes a lot of time for you to get
good at the skill as well as for you to
build up momentum and a name in the
industry you have to do a lot of free
speaking gigs before you ever get paid
to do it so if you have a horizon of
years awesome but I'd rather you start
get paid immediately while we work on
the speaking career you want to be an
author and get paid to have a book cool
you can go and sell publish a book right
now if you wanted to you can get it out
you'll make you know you can sell it to
your friends and family your your
audience you'll make a a few bucks but
it's not going to be anything meaningful
to get a paid deal or to have a
significant even if you're going
self-publishing to make a lot of money
off your book you have to have a big
audience
to get the deal with a publisher they
want you to have at least a hundred
thousand followers that's like your
starting point to get in so is that
achievable of course but now we're
looking at years as a horizon as opposed
to like this has to happen right away so
you're not getting paid right now off of
your book so if you're sitting there
thinking write in a book creating a
great manuscript creating a great how-to
guide it's not going to be the thing
that helps get you any kind of money
anytime soon and I want you to get paid
because most people quit too soon on
their ideas or they're trying to do a
million different things at once right
if you're trying to create a course
same thing you have to build up enough
momentum you spend so much time making a
course creating the content filming
videos or writing instruction manuals or
creating the PDFs or whatever your
course structure is it takes so long to
make the course
and then you have to go and Market the
course and people don't know who you are
yet you don't have a brand yet so could
it work absolutely will it pay you more
than coaching yes absolutely most likely
it's way more easy to leverage that than
coaching
but again the timeline is so long
and most people quit too soon on it
where if you were coaching you can you
can make money right away as long as you
have something that can actually help
people right if you're good at what you
do you know how to solve somebody's
problem you can make money as a coach
right away and yes you're trading your
time for money but it's better than
having a job and it also gets you closer
to your customers at the very beginning
that much I'm a much bigger fan of
selling a service and a product because
it gets you closer to your customers you
get to know their problems you know
their issues you know what exactly
they're struggling with and you can help
them solve it which allows you to create
a better book a better course a better
product because you've worked with
enough people through the problem and so
most entrepreneurs fall into the
category I want to do all of it great I
want to be a speaker I want to be an
author I want to create my course I want
to create my book I want to be a coach I
want to do all of it awesome you have a
limited amount of time every week
to work on all five of those things at
the same time means there's very little
progress how if that's you and you've
been writing your book how long you've
been writing your book for
you're like when is it going to come out
what year
how many speaking gigs have you done in
the past three months
all right how much time has gone into
your course it's like we start and stop
and start and stop because we're
tackling so many different things
because you want to do it all and you
want to have income streams coming in
like crazy and there's nothing wrong
with that it's amazing but there's a
sequence
there's an order
that if you can as soon as possible
inside of your purpose
start to make money start to build
momentum start to be able to bring on
team to help you it's so much easier you
can go so much further you can go so
much faster you can have so much less
stress
you can have such a big impact
that you just need to focus
you just need to focus
it's all possible your big dreams are
possible
go in order figure out the sequence that
will start to get you paid
Focus
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome if you
want to watch another top 10 rules of
Evan Carmichael check out the video next
to me continue to believe I will see you
there get clear on what you want what do
you want make it super clear you can't
just want a better life what does that
look like get super clear on what it is
that you are going after